>>> A SOURCE IN HAITI'S SECURITY
FORCES TELLS CNN THAT ONE OF THE
COUNTRY'S MOST POWERFUL GANGS IS
BELIEVED TO BE BEHIND THE
KIDNAPPING OF 17 MISSIONARIES
OVER THE WEEKEND.
16 OF THE 17 KIDNAPPING VICTIMS
ARE AMERICANS, ONE IS CANADIAN.
AUTHORITIES BELIEVE THE 400
MAWOZO GANG ABDUCTED THE GROUP
AFTER THE MISSIONARIES VISITED
AN ORPHANAGE ON SATURDAY IN A
SUBURB NORTHEAST OF
PORT-AU-PRINCE.
CNN'S MATT RIVERS IS THERE WITH
THE LATEST.
>> Reporter: A DESPERATE CALL
FOR HELP AS SEEN IN A WHATSAPP
MESSAGE OBTAINED BY CNN.
THE MESSAGE READS PLEASE PRAY
FOR US, WE ARE BEING HARASSED,
KIDNAPPED CURRENTLY.
THEY HAVE CONTROL OF OUR VEHICLE
WITH ABOUT 15 AMERICANS RIGHT
NOW.
LADIES, MEN, AND CHILDREN.
HE THEN SAYS THEY ARE NEAR THE
PLACE A SOURCE IN HAITI'S
SECURITY FORCES CONFIRMS IS
WHERE THE GROUP WAS ABDUCTED.
12 ADULTS, ALONG WITH FIVE
CHILDREN ACCORDING TO CHRISTIAN
AID MINISTRIES.
AND WE ARE LEARNING MORE ABOUT
THE GANG WHO MAY BE BEHIND THE
CRIME.
OUR SOURCE SAYING IT'S THE 400
MAWOZO GANG.
ONE OF, IF NOT THE MOST,
POWERFUL IN THE COUNTRY, ITS
DOZENS OF MEMBERS WITH A
DISTINCT HALLMARK, KIDNAPPING.
NEARLY A YEAR AGO, THE GANG'S
ALLEGED LEADER SAID ME, I WORK,
I'M A GANGSTER, I CARRY WEAPONS.
I'M IN A GANG, I HAVE GUNS.
I DON'T CARRY WEAPONS TO
TERRORIZE.
CARRYING WEAPONS DOESN'T MAKE ME
A GANGSTER OR A BANDIT.
SEVERAL MILES DOWN THAT ROAD
THERE IS WHERE OUR SOURCE SAYS
THIS KIDNAPPING WAS CARRIED OUT
IN A MORE NORMAL SITUATION, WE
WOULD DRIVE SEVERAL MILES DOWN
THAT ROAD AND GO SEE EXACTLY
WHERE THIS TOOK PLACE.
BUT FOLLOWING THE ADVICE OF BOTH
OUR HAITIAN PRODUCER AND OUR
SECURITY TEAM, WE ARE NOT GOING
TO GO ANY FURTHER THAN THIS
BECAUSE THEY SAY IT'S NOT SAFE.
DOWN THAT ROAD IS THE SUBURB
WHICH IS ESSENTIALLY COMPLETELY
CONTROLLED BY THE 400 MAWOZO
GANG.
THE GANG THAT AUTHORITIES SAY
CARRIED OUT THIS KIDNAPPING.
THAT GANG AND OTHERS HAVE
TERRORIZED HAITI FOR YEARS WITH
KIDNAPPINGS EXPLODING SINCE
JANUARY ACCORDING TO A HUMAN
RIGHTS NONPROFIT BASED IN
PORT-AU-PRINCE.
FOREIGNERS GET THE ATTENTION BUT
IT'S ORDINARY HAITIANS THAT ARE
THE VAST MAJORITY OF KIDNAPPING
VICTIMS DATA FROM THE
ORGANIZATION SHOWS.
THIS MAN SAYS KIDNAPPINGS HERE
HAVE BEEN HAPPENING FOR SO LONG,
WHY DID NO ONE TALK ABOUT IT
THEN?
WHY IS THE WORLD MAKING SUCH A
BIG DEAL ABOUT FOREIGNERS?
IT'S BECAUSE THEY'RE MORE
IMPORTANT.
ON MONDAY, HAITIANS ACROSS THE
CAPITAL REGION TOOK ADVANTAGE OF
THE RENEWED ATTENTION BY STAYING
HOME.
SCHOOLS AND BUSINESSES AND
TRANSPORT SERVICES SHUT DOWN.
NORMALLY, PACKED PORT-AU-PRINCE
STREETS EMPTY.
IT WAS A QUIET FORM OF PROTEST.
PEOPLE DEMANDING SAFETY AND
SECURITY FROM A GOVERNMENT IN
TURMOIL.
NOBODY IS SAFE, SAYS THIS MAN.
EVEN NORMAL PEOPLE GOING OUT TO
BUY FOOD GET KIDNAPPED.
IT'S EVEN WORSE FOR SOMEONE IN A
CAR.
THERE IS SO MUCH FEAR IN THE
COUNTRY, EVEN PEOPLE LIVING
OUTSIDE THE COUNTRY ARE AFRAID
TO COME BACK.
AND SO, ANDERSON, THE AMOUNT OF
KIDNAPPINGS HERE IN HAITI HAS
JUST SKYROCKETED.
REALLY, GOING ALL THE WAY BACK
TO THE BEGINNING OF 2021.
BUT THEN, THE PRESIDENT WAS
ASSASSINATED IN JULY.
THERE WAS A FEW-WEEK LULL.
AND THEN EVER SINCE THEN,
ACCORDING TO NONPROFIT DATA FROM
A GROUP HERE IN PORT-AU-PRINCE
THAT TRACKS THIS, KIDNAPPINGS
HAVE RISEN MORE THAN 300%.
AND THIS AREA WHERE THIS GROUP
OF MISSIONARIES WAS, IT IS
NOTORIOUS AS BEING ONE OF THE
WORST PLACES FOR PEOPLE TO BE
AND FRANKLY IT RAISES QUESTIONS
AT THE ORGANIZATIONAL LEVEL.
WHY WAS THIS AID -- THIS
MISSIONARY GROUP WHICH HAS
WORKED IN HAITI FOR SOME TIME
NOW ALLOWING ITS PEOPLE TO BE IN
AN AREA THAT A